[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de covile 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire le monde
médical mais aussi les ex ministres et
directeurs généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous faire revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de martin
hirsch le président des hôpitaux de
paris et celle de christophe gauthier
directeur du chu de strasbourg deux
régions en première ligne pendant
l'épidémie
nous attaquons la crise si je puis dire
dans les pires conditions
il nous manque à peu près 1000
personnels soignants de postes vacants
phénomène qui s'est accentuée pendant
toute l'année 2019 et nous nous trouvons
donc dans une situation dans laquelle il
faut avoir conscience que nous avions
des lits de soins critiques qui étaient
fermés été comme hiver fou par manque de
personnel pour des raisons structurelles
dont j'espère qu'elles seront corrigés
rapidement puisque vous allusion à ce
qui fallait pour se préparer pour la
suite et malgré cela nous avons pu
quasiment tripler nos capacités de soins
critiques avec une mobilisation du
personnel des changements d'horaires la
mobilisation de renforts à hauteur
d'environ 10000 personnes incluant sous
l'autorité du doyen des doyens les
personnels en formation qu'ils soient
étudiants en médecine ou qu'ils soient
étudiants infirmiers et également des
équipes qui sont venus de toute la
france en renfort et c'est pour ça que
nous considérons que nous devons le
rendre quand il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'aider la guyane qui connaît des
difficultés
je vais prendre juste quelques minutes
pour dire je pense que vous êtes aussi
informer vous êtes très informés du
point de vue de la direction de
l'assistance publique
quels sont le type de décisions
importantes qu'on a été conduit à
prendre l'une des nominés l'une des
décisions importantes a été de
s'organiser complètement en mode de
crise en faisant quelque chose qui est
simple c'est que d'appliquer le plan
blanc la deuxième chose qui est très
précoce
c'est d'avoir créé un dispositif qui
rappelle qu vie d'homme permettant de
prendre en charge des patients sans
qu'ils aient besoin de se déplacer ou de
venir à l'hôpital pendant cette période
on a pris en charge 75 mille patients
quinze mille patients dans nos lits
soixante mille patients dans leur lit
kovy d'hommes qui est un système de
suivi à distance et qui étaient
organisés de manière remarquable
je ne mets pas les lauriers pour moi mes
lauriers pour les acteurs puisqu'il a
fait participer à peu près la moitié des
médecins généralistes d'ile-de-france
qui ont intégré inclus et suivi des
patients
sas a changé la donne c'est parce que
nous savions que nous lisions toutes les
places que nous pouvions ouvrir que nous
avons exprimé le besoin de non seulement
avoir le recours des professionnels qui
viennent nous aider mais de pouvoir
procéder à des évacuations sanitaires et
les évacuations sanitaires ont lieu
elles ont eu lieu entre la fin du mois
de mars
je crois entre le 26 mars et les trois
semaines qui ont suivi
elles ont sauvé des vies les évacuations
sanitaires ont sauvé des vies
j'entendais récemment des critiques
disons que c'était de la paillette la
paillette ne sauve pas de vie les
évacuations sanitaires sauve des vies
elles ont sauvé des vies en ile de
france et je pense que mes collègues de
l'est ne diront pas différent non pour
ce qu'ils ont connu
donc le siège de strasbourg a été très
tôt concernés évidemment par cette vague
épidémique nous avons hébergé notre
premier patient le 25 février
et pour donner une idée de la cinétique
de l'épidémie le 3 mars nous avions aux
premiers patients en réanimation le 16
mars il y avait 149 patients qu'aux vide
dont 54 en réanimation et le 2 avril
nous atteignons notre pic avec 601
patientes dont 180 en réanimation ce qui
donne l'idée de la cinétique ont connu
pour laquelle nous avons été confrontés
nous avons été jusqu'à 4 125 lits
spécialisés
pour l'hébergement du coup vide alors
que l'unité de maladies infectieuses
donc remporté que 40 à l'origine et puis
surtout les capacités de réanimation qui
ont été multipliés par un coefficient de
2 et demi à l'échelle du territoire
c'est pratiquement un coefficient de
droit qui a été qui a été utilisé et ce
qui a été l'enjeu le plus important
environ dans la mobilisation à la fois
des équipes du matériel nous avons
réussi à passer le cap
grâce à la solidarité nationale et
internationale en entamant une politique
de transfert dès le 22 mars c'est le
premier transfert à destination de
l'allemagne
et nous avons également inaugurer si je
désire le le premier train médicalisé
qui est parti de strasbourg le 26 mars
je rejoins tout à fait les propos de
martin hirsch était un peu heurtés par
ces polémiques récentes sur l'intérêt de
ces évacuations sanitaires ils ont été
indispensables pour permettre à chaque
patient de pouvoir bénéficier des soins
adaptés à son état
et pour arriver à la conclusion sur les
1856 patiente nous avons accueilli au
c'est juste strasbourg dont 492 en
réanimation tous et j'insiste là-dessus
ont pu bénéficier des soins adaptés leur
état y compris en réanimation lourde
grâce à ces dispositifs d'évacuation
sanitaire c'était tout à fait capital
monsieur directeur général de
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
peut-être précision puisque vont c'est
sans doute pas le sujet essentiel de
cette audition mais on a vu les
polémiques que personnellement je trouve
un peu inopportune mais bon elle
s'installe et vaut mieux les clarifier
qui ont qui ont eu lieu nous avons tous
vu votre prise de position par rapport
aux déclarations qui avaient été tenus
ici même par le professeur raoul tu sur
des chiffres qui ont été publiés donc
peut-être préalablement aux questions
qu'on peut vous poser serait utile
contrôler la présidente que vous ayez
peut-être une expression sur ces deux
sujets qui ont fait débat
oui bien sûr monsieur le rapporteur
je viens de prêter serment comme
j'imagine le professeur out avait prêté
serment
effectivement je me suis permis de
après avoir vu les réactions que cela
suscitait au sein de la paix de réagir
en tout cas sur deux points
premier point sur deux accusations
graves qui sont partout la première
accusation c'est que on aurait laissé
ressortir par ignorance et par
incompétence
un patient atteint de qu'ovide rentrer
chez lui
contaminé sa fille puis ensuite qu'on
aurait réhospitalisé ceci est mensonger
c'est d'ailleurs publiés dans les revues
scientifiques puisque dans les revues
scientifiques les premiers cas ont été 1
1 décrit le patient dont il est question
est rentré dans un service d'urgence
le samedi 24 ou 25 janvier a
effectivement compte tenu des critères
qui était portée par santé publique
france pas considéré comme suspect de
covile à l'époque mais traitée comme
telle c'est à dire qu'il a été masquée
les personnels a été masquée il n'est
jamais ressortie de l'hôpital jamais
ressortie de l'hôpital
il est passé en réanimation et il est
allé en réanimation dans le centre de
référence de bichat où il a été pris en
charge
sa fille a été pris en charge ce patient
pour des raisons qu'ils ont expliqué
dans l'article est lui décédé
sa fille a été sauvée donc je réfute ce
qui a été dit sur notre négligence ou
notre incompétence c'est factuellement
faux sur ce qui est née taux de
mortalité en réanimation qui vous ont
été présentés en dix ans 43% à
l'assistance publique
en s'appuyant sur une petite feuille du
14 avril
je pense que l'audition était à la fin
du mois de juin et en comparant un taux
de mortalité à marseille qui serait de
16 7%
sous-entendant que nous serions des
criminels
puis que nous aurions laissé mourir des
patients avec un taux de mortalité
triple de celui de marseille parce que
nous n'aurions pas donner le médicament
c'était ça à peu près le raisonnement
donc là aussi j'ai attiré votre
attention sur le fait que le taux sur
plusieurs choses d'abord le taux de
mortalité dans les services de soins
critiques de l'ap-hp ne sont pas de 43%
on estime si on prend et si vous prenez
alors premièrement nous ne savons pas et
personne ne peut donner aujourd'hui le
taux de mortalité définitif pour une
bonne raison
nous avons encore des patients qui sont
en réanimation et que nous espérons
sauver donc le taux de réanimation le
taux de mortalité ne sera connu que dans
quelques semaines si on prend les taux
de mortalité tels qu'on les voit
aujourd'hui on peut avoir deux sources
une source qui est civique qui est le
dispositif officiel
l'application pilotée par la direction
générale de la santé qui demande à
chaque établissement de santé de
recenser tous les patients qui rentrent
dans les services de soins critiques et
il ressort aujourd'hui à la paix à 25%
et nous avons eu notre mode de travail
avec une cohorte mis en place une étude
de l'ensemble des cas un par un et pour
lequel nous estimons aujourd'hui que le
taux de mortalité pour être de 31 à 35 %
en tout cas pas de 43%
je ne prétends pas et aucun d'entre nous
ne prétend connaître celui de marseille
j'attire juste le fait que les
comparaisons comme cela dépend de
beaucoup de choses
il se trouve que nous à la paix on sait
dire que plus de 10 % des patientes qui
sont en réanimation ont eu besoin
d'avoir recours à la circulation
extracorporelle place et du son
pour insuffisance défaillance mes
voisins pourront le dire que moi
respiratoire extrêmement forte
je ne sais pas ce qu'il est dans les
autres établissements
mais il nous nous avons par exemple que
par rapport à l'italie c'est beaucoup
plus élevé et donc que c'est des
patients plus sévère deuxième chose en
fonction du nombre de patients pris en
charge quand vous avez peu de patients à
prendre en charge
vous pouvez mettre des patients plus
léger en réanimation alors que quand
vous avez beaucoup de passion à prendre
en charge
vous faites en sorte que ce soit les
passions graves qui aient accès aux
réanimation ce qui a une influence sur
le taux de mortalité pour pouvoir
comparer les taux de mortalité
il faut faire des études qu'ils soient
sérieuses c'est pour ça que nous avons
lancé un programme qui s'appelle
qu'ovide haïti ue pour soins critiques
unités de soins critiques permettant de
pouvoir connaître les différences en
connaissant l'âge en fonction des pas le
taux de mortalité des patients de plus
de 80 en réanimation est bien plus élevé
que les autres
donc si vous avez soit 4 % soit 6 % de
patients de plus de 80 ans a une
influence considérable sur vos taux de
mortalité donc si vous connaissez pas
l'âge les comorbidités l'état de gravité
et à vous ne pouvez pas comparer est
aujourd'hui lié à ma connaissance aucune
étude scientifique publiée qui permet de
comparer les taux donc je ne prononce
pas sur les autres
je dis que ce qui a été dit et
sous-entendus sur ce qui s'est passé
dans les hôpitaux de la paix est
contraire à la réalité aux chiffres
alors le courrier que vous avez transmis
comme celui de la haute autorité de
santé du comité scientifique ont été les
courriers ont été transmis à chaque
membre de la mission nous prenons acte
de ce que vous venez de dire sachant que
chacun l'un et l'autre étant sous
serment
voilà donc c'est un rappel pour toutes
les auditions qui auront lieu et
personne non plus n'est là pour juger
l'assistance publique les hôpitaux de
paris loin s'en faut mais au contraire
salué le travail que vous avez pu faire
donc voila j'aimerais que maintenant on
puisse passer justement à tout ce qui a
pu
ce faire ou pas se faire ou traînés
parce que c'est ça la gestion de la
crise qu'on doit voir merci aux
rapporteurs d'avoir rappelé votre foyer
je vais poursuivre sous votre contrôle à
la présidente
donc ce document qui nous a été adressé
le registre ray vase qui date en effet
du 14 avril mais c'est un document exact
jeu qui évoque un taux de 43 % mais à
une date donnée à donner mais c'est ça
ce donc ce chiffre vient de dollars
puisque ça a été adressée cas là ça a
été adressée à la c1 tout à la fois ce
tableau vient de chez nous mais ce
tableau
si vous regardez la page d'avant il est
rappelé qu'à 50% des patients qui ne
sont pas sortis
donc qui ne compte pas dans le
dénominateur par rapport à dans votre
réponse sur ce sujet on va plus en fin
de compte ce qui me concerne plus en
parler mais vous évoquez notamment ceux
de questions qui me paraissent
essentiels sur la prise en charge des
patients en réanimation passe de façon
globale s'est posé la question est ce
qu'on prend en compte toutes les
personnes âgées très âgées est ce qu'il
ya une forme de régulation ou pas donc
vous avez évoqué un âge des patients
animations notamment des personnes très
âgées puis vous nous avez dit à
l'instant selon les cas si si on a de la
place ou pas on met que les cas les plus
les plus graves
donc comment s'est effectuée je sais pas
si le terme est exact mais la régulation
dans l'accueil des passants d'un des
patients dans les services de soins
critiques
je ne vous donne pas la parole
mais prenez là quand vous voulez
répondre quand une question s'adresse
plus ou moins à l'un et l'autre je ne
veux pas qu'on monopolise toujours mais
quand le rapporteur pose une question il
s'adresse à l'ensemble et prenez la
réponse qui vous dans l'ordre que vous
souhaitez merci nous notre côté le
travail qu'on a réalisé ce qu'on vous
exposer sur l'augmentation du nombre de
lits de soins critiques étaient pour ne
pas priver de possibilités d'accès aux
soins critiques les patients et de
garder pendant toute la période de la
crise une situation dans laquelle ce qui
comptait c'était les critères médicaux
est-ce que l'admission en soins
critiques va aider un patient ou est ce
qu'on considère pendant la période
est ce qu'on considère que ça ne va pas
l'aider et toutes les réunions de crise
auquel on a assisté avec notamment mes
deux voisins ont consistait à faire en
sorte qu effectivement on puisse
maintenir le même type de critère en
période de crise que les critères
qu'utilisent les réanimateurs hors
période de crise où même quand une
réanimation évident un patient dont il
pense que le fait de le soumettre au
traitement agressif de l'intuber ne va
pas le
les dés qu'il n'y ait pas de différence
dans ce conte faire berner et c'est pour
ça qu'on a fait l'expansion de ces
réanimation on s'est concentrés pour ce
qui nous concerne sur les patients les
plus lourds en réanimation ce qui
explique que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
de ce taux extrêmement élevé de patients
bénéficiant d'une assistance
circulatoire dit les mots de telle sorte
que l'on puisse avoir
là où les soins sont les plus les
soirées les plus lourds les patients
également les plus lourds ce qui nous a
conduit à ne pas organiser de tri entre
les patients on se l est exactement dans
le même sens nous ont été extrêmement
attentif à cela et tous les critères qui
président à l admission en réanimation
pendant la crise était identique à ceux
qui préexistait avant la crise et l'âge
est un facteur parmi d'autres et dans
les critères d'éligibilité la balance
bénéfice-risque l admission en
réanimation a toujours été pesées et
comme le disait un instant martin hirsch
est ce qui a conditionné cette expansion
très importante des capacités
d'animation de façon ne jamais être sous
le critère limitatif de capacités et
c'est ce que nous avons réussi à faire
et je veux souligner tout à l'heure dans
le cas notamment des évacuations
sanitaires lorsque cette capacité
maximale a été atteinte de façon à
permettre toujours pour les patients un
bénéfice des meilleures techniques de
réanimation possible jeu juste sur ce
sujet puis ça sera ma dernière question
pour le point est en tout cas la prend
sur le dans vos deux nombre de régions
il ya eu des ehpad qui ont été
lourdement lors de ma lourdement touchée
dans 30 des cas eu dans un établissement
plusieurs dizaines de morts également
sur sur paris année annick de france des
établissements lourdement touchés
comment a été la relation avec ces
établissements quel stade la prise en
charge at elle été effectués bon il ya
eu un débat vous n'ignorez pas sur la
là aussi sur la prise en charge en amont
de ces patients sur la régulation est ce
qu'il n'aurait pas dû être hospitalisé
plus tôt pourquoi ne l'ont ils pas été
est ce que les médecins coordonnateurs
de ces ehpad ont mis en contact avec les
autorités de régulation et comment ça
s'est passé voilà j'aimerai avoir sur
ces points parce que vous êtes deux
régions où il ya eu des déçus des cas il
y en a eu dans d'autres y compris dans
la mienne aussi très grave
et comment s'est opérée ce lien histoire
de santé de la création d'une équipe
mobile qui a été d'ailleurs ceux listés
par l' agence une équipe mobile qui
était coordonnée par un médecin gériatre
des hôpitaux universitaires de
strasbourg qui a été en contact avec les
médecins coordonnateurs des ehpad à leur
demande en tout cas qui s'est rendu
pleinement disponible de façon à pouvoir
évaluer discuter des bonnes pratiques
répondre aux transferts aux demandes de
transfert lorsqu'elles ont été formulées
et c'est effectivement pour nous ça a
été un atout important dans cette
création d'une des mobiles pardon qui
étaient mises à la disposition des
médecins coordonnateurs des ehpad qui
ont souhaité recourir à ces à ses
services et à ses avis merci j'ai passé
la parole à jean pierre door pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente mais mesdames
et messieurs les directeurs donc de la
paix puis de strasbourg
les questions qui ont été sujettes à
discussion
c'était la pénurie pénurie des masques
aux pénuries des blues pénurie d des
matériels de protection à quel moment où
quel stade vous avez pu apporter une
réponse efficace à ces pénuries et est
ce que vous aviez en stock on peut dire
les stocks dormants des masques de
l'époque h à hénin h5n1 comme vous
pouviez les avoirs et à quel niveau
qu'elles stockent qu'est le volume était
présent à cette époque là la pénurie de
médicaments particules
les fameux curare les médicaments
anesthésiques qui sont utiles en
réanimation
comment avez vous pu répondre à ces
pénuries ont elles été effectivement
efficace
et puis je voudrais savoir effectivement
comment s'est passé le lien entre les
établissements publics qui sont les
vôtres et les établissements privés en
particulier en ile-de-france où certains
établissements privés ont dit à un
moment qu'il y avait eu du retard à
l'allumage et qu'il attendait
effectivement qui est une réponse et des
transferts cpt le public et le privé
comment s'est organisé sept est ce qu'il
y avait une cartographie alors j'ai bien
c'était sous la direction de la rs mais
comment ça a pu s'organiser
comment c'était jour par jour le nombre
de lits le nombre de respirateurs vous
aviez ces statistiques là et puis bien
entendu il faudrait avoir un bilan du
renoncement les soins on commence à en
parler beaucoup de savoir entre le les
interventions chirurgicales entre les
retards de renoncement aux soins comment
ça s'est passé dans les services de vos
établissements moi je suis dans un
service de régionales donc j'ai vu
comment ça se passe et où on pouvait
différé mais dans les hôpitaux comme la
pitié salpêtrière où les autres hôpitaux
au strasbourg ou comment ça s'est passé
sur le plan de ce renoncement de soins
est-ce que vous avez déjà des bilans des
statistiques merci merci je vais vous
demander de prendre des notes parce que
je vais passer deux ou trois questions
de parlementaires david habib pour les
socialistes
merci madame la présidente moi je
voudrais d'abord vous interrogez juste
sur la pénurie
on se souvient tous à la voie du fait
que la ministre de la santé nous avait
indiqué que dès le mois de décembre
à la fin du mois décembre à mesurer les
effets de ce qui allait arriver et en
même temps que la première commande
c'était 1 5 million c'est bien ça de
masquer 20 janvier est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire juste pour notre
information soit sur strasbourg ça sur
paris
les besoins en masques qui sont les
vôtres pour une semaine les besoins
hospitaliers deuxième deuxième sujet que
je souhaite aborder c'est la question de
la fin de vie dans quelles conditions
les personnes atteintes du coc vite 19
sont-elles décédé dans vos
établissements
quelles consignes particulières mais
vous donnez à vos personnels pour les
accompagner dans ces moments qui était
douloureux pour aussi votre personnel
comment vous avez géré cette situation
en gérance et y at il eu pour parler
très clairement vous avez répondu en
partie à notre rapporteur eric ciotti
mais je souhaiterais que les choses
soient claires at il eu il y at il eu un
tri des patients deuxième deuxième volet
c'est la situation du personnel soignant
est ce que vous pouvez nous dire le
nombre de personnels soignants qui ont
été victimes du coc vide le nombre
malheureusement de personnes du
personnel qui seraient décédées ou sont
décédés du cobp id qu'elles ont été
comment vous avez géré les cellules les
cellules post traumatique les cellules
d'accompagnement
quel est ce que vous avez fait pu faire
appel vous l'avais dit il ya tout à
l'heure il manquait mille en 2010 9000
postes comment vous avez pu gérer
l'appel aux renforts de personnel et
puis dernier point j'en finis madame la
présidente vous avez parlé d'évacuation
sanitaire
ma question s'adresse aux tous les deux
mais je pense ce qui sauve gauthier
comprendra peut-être cette question le
vous avez fait appel à l'allemagne
inversement
moi je n'ai pas vu de deux patients
étrangers venus en france et dans un
département qui est celui du père
l'atlantique
il y avait 60 lits en réanimation il n'y
a pas eu une pratiquement aucun lit
proposé aux autorités espagnoles
qu'est ce qui ferait alors je vous
demande pas vous n'êtes pas ministre de
la santé en tout cas pas l'heure mais
qu'est ce qui ferait que
yanji qu'est ce qui doit être fait pour
qu'il y ait une gestion qui soient
davantage européennes de ce type de
pandémie
comment on peut apporter une réponse au
niveau des autorités européennes
merci et sophie auconie merci à la
présidente mais madame messieurs les
directeurs lors d'une d'un interview
dans les échos
monsieur hirsch du 24 mai dernier vous
avez indiqué un certain nombre vous avez
mis en exergue un certain nombre de
problématiques que rencontrent le
personnel hospitalier et la gouvernance
hospitalière et vous indiquer que dans
le cadre de cette crise nous avons su
dépasser un certain nombre de clivage un
certain nombre de pesanteurs vous
indiquer que sous prétexte de qualité et
de sécurité des soins
l'hôpital français et le plus normé au
monde ce en quoi je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous et ce depuis 20 ans
que la pesanteur et les pesanteurs
bureaucratiques
vous empêche de travailler empêche une
certaine forme d'efficacité au sein des
services hospitaliers que les clivages
entretenu entre l'administratif et le
médical le pouvoir administratif de
pouvoir médical notamment dans la
gouvernance des hôpitaux est un
véritable sujet moi c'est toujours ma
question dans cette dans le cas de
s'être de cette de cette commission
denquête est ce que notre organisation
est réellement efficace il faut que
cette commission denquête participe à
améliorer le fonctionnement de
l'organisation de la santé dans notre
dans nos territoires mais aussi des
gouvernance des hôpitaux
quand je vois qu'il y a dix salariés
administratifs pour 10 personnels
soignants je me demande si ces gages
réellement d'efficacité ou gage de sueur
administration lourde
enfin la rigidification des statuts vous
nous indiquer que dans ce cadre là que
c'est une réalité et que pour sortir
qu'un certain nombre de personnels sort
du cadre qui devrait les protéger
parce qu'il est trop complexe je vois
aussi par exemple tout ce qui est lié à
l'intérim
des médecins qui démissionnent de leurs
postes à l'hôpital et qui viennent dix
fois plus rémunérés d'après certains en
intérim à l'hôpital comment peut-on
mettre un terme à ce genre de
dysfonctionnement évidemment impact le
budget des hôpitaux en général merci
alors monsieur gautier monsieur vous
vous organiser je vais démarrer se
permettaient sur quelques d'abord sur
lui sur les masques évidemment qui est
un sujet de préoccupation majeur je vais
essayer d'apporter quelques éléments
monsieur le député précis sur les
masques nous sommes bien sûr dans la
suite et votre commission en a été saisi
de l'instruction du 16 mai 2013 donc qui
confiait évidemment à l'employeur la
responsabilité de son stock elle était
complétée aussi par une instruction du
15 mai 2014 sur la gestion du stock
tactique et donc la gestion du stock
tactique fait objet fait l'objet d'une
description d'un financement d'ailleurs
par une mission d'intérêt général avec
un objectif très très définis par les
circulaires la façon pour nous de faire
face à cette obligation ce n'était la
passation d'un marché ouvert un marché
ouvert
d'ailleurs partenaire du centre d'achat
et à peut pas tout laisser et je suis
émarge à ce marché avec donc une
possibilité de commande non fermées en
quelque sorte est tout à fait adapté
évidemment au besoin je vais en donner
quelques quelques illustrations pour le
pôle chu de strasbourg en consommation
mensuelle moyenne au siège du strasbourg
sur les masques chirurgicaux nous en
sommes donc en 2d 114000 à peu près et
nous avons un stock qui a été un stock
maximum de 225 mille masques donne 30
jours de stock sur les masques
chirurgicaux avec une procédure de
déclenchement de nouvelles commandes dès
que le stock descendait à un niveau en
l'occurrence autour de 20 jours le délai
de rats provisionnement était un délai
moyen de 5 jours ton courrier qu'on a
était toujours en théorie en capacité de
pouvoir nous approvisionner la seule
chose qui n'était pas prévisible
évidemment c'est la rupture de les
filières d'approvisionnement
c'est l'incapacité qu'ont eue les
fournisseurs à pouvoir répondre aux
commandes que nous passions mais le
système lui-même dans un système dans
lequel cette filière d'approvisionnement
aurait été continu n'aurait pas posé de
difficultés puisque encore une fois ce
seuil de déclenchement de nos stocks
nous a toujours permis évidemment de
faire face pour répondre très
précisément la question de monsieur
députés nous ont eu des tensions qui
sont apparues à peu près au milieu du
mois de février et nous avons commencé à
être livrée livré sur le stock national
à compter du 6 mars et aux hôpitaux
verseuse strasbourg nous avons huit
livraison entre le 6 mars et le 11 mai
qui nous ont approvisionné à hauteur de
pratiquement 2 millions de masques
chirurgicaux à aucun moment aux hôpitaux
ni à sa seconde nous n'avons été
confrontés à une pénurie nettes c'est à
dire que l'ensemble des masques en
conformité des doctrines du
utilisation et je vais je pourrais
prolonger cet élément ont toujours été
présents grâce à l'approvisionnement sur
le stock national donc nous n'avons pas
eu de rupture nette de masques dont eu
des phases évidemment de tension
notamment dans la phase du 4 au 23 mars
et en application de la doctrine qui a
était un peu plus restrictive sur
l'utilisation du masque ffp2 réserve et
simplement aux gestes invasifs
mais nous n'avons pas connu de rupture
et c'est heureux dans
l'approvisionnement de masques donc
voilà pour prendre pour les pour
répondre précisément sur cette question
sur cette question des masques sur les
autres questions posées peut-être
monsieur députés sur la coopération
établissements publics et privés elles
étaient assez remarquable dans notre
secteur nous avons très vite installé
une cellule de coordination à l'échelle
de notre territoire qui a permis
d'installer cette régulation et une
participation active des établissements
privés qui ont d'ailleurs obtenu de
façon dérogatoire et rapide des
autorisations de réanimation ce qui leur
a permis de pleinement joué leur rôle
dans l'accueil des patients dont pour
nous ça n'a pas été un sujet de
difficulté et cette coordination
territoriale a pleinement joué je crois
sans son rôle les retards de soins vous
avez évoqué ce sont d'autres sujets de
préoccupation
l'arrêt de l'activité chirurgicale qui
était chez nous massif la difficulté
aussi de reprise de cette activité avec
un certain nombre de règles qui viennent
limiter la reprise pleine et entière
d'activité je pense à l'utilisation bien
sûr des chambres à de vie qui est rendu
plus difficile je pense aux protocoles
sanitaires très strictes qui ralentisse
l'activité opératoire font que c'est
pour nous un sujet majeur de
préoccupation c'est peut-être même le
sujet aujourd'hui de procuration pour
lequel nous essayons de déployer tous
nos efforts pour permettre en
redémarrage le plus normal de l'activité
avec une gestion des files actives de
patientes qui réalisait au plus près par
les équipes médicales et en particulier
dans les sujets de priorisation
d'intervention puisque les gestes semi
urgente était décalé ils deviennent
urgents maintenant et chaque équipe
médicale fait un suivi extrêmement
attentif des situations individuelles de
façon à déterminer des critères
d'éligibilité et de ne pas causer
évidemment de dommages partie
mais évidemment un sujet tout à fait
important pour répondre aux questions de
monsieur le député sur les fins de vie
elles ont été effectivement douloureuse
pour les familles dans des conditions on
va dire de strict respect des protocoles
n'a tenté d'être dans la plus grande
humanité à sion en particulier en
autorisant même si c'était dans légère
dérogation par rapport au contrôle
strict des des présences en service de
réanimation pour les fins de vie lorsque
ses fins de vie était inéluctable et on
a essayé d'être vraiment dans une
approche qui concilie à la fois les
exigences très strictes
un de l'observation des règles et en
même temps la plus grande humanité
je répond de façon très claire à votre
question sur le tri des patients il n'y
a pas eu monsieur le député de tri des
patients ce que je disais sur les
critères de réanimation ont été
scrupuleusement observés et des critères
qui ont été appliqués un très grand
nombre de patients étaient exactement
les mêmes qu'avant le déclenchement de
la crise dont les critères médicaux sur
l'éligibilité sur le bénéfice risque
encore une fois de la réanimation sans
que le critère de disponibilité ne soit
un critère qui viennent induire une
notion de tri il est très important de
préciser et ça a été le cas pour
l'ensemble de nos patients sur nos
personnels près de 600 de nos collègues
ont été au chu de strasbourg atteint 1
de kovy decaux vide
un seul décès sur un collaborateur
occasionnel d'ailleurs un médecin
vacataires donc six ans c'est
effectivement important sur douze mille
cinq cents salariés avec un suivi
extrêmement attentif de la part de la
médecine du travail
des dépistages pour nous qui ont été
systématiques des mesures de précaution
pour les cas contact avec un port de
masques pour les cas contacts ils ont
d'ailleurs conduit dès le 23 mars a
préconisé le port de masques généralisée
pour l'ensemble des acteurs à
l'intérieur des hôpitaux compte tenu de
la dissémination de ces cas évidemment
et de nécessité de pouvoir protéger le
leurs collègues
donc on a été vraiment dans un souci
majeur qui se poursuit aujourd'hui la
mise en place d'une cellule
psychologique s'appelle kovy psy aux
hôpitaux universitaires de strasbourg
qui suit effectivement nos équipes et
qu'il fait je crois de façon
tout à fait tout à fait attentive voilà
en quelques mots les questions que je
pouvais apporter sur alors sur la
question des masques au début mars
d'abord sur la consommation de masse
pour vous donner pour répondre à l'autre
à votre question
l'année dernière nous utilisions par
jour
trente sept mille masques chirurgicaux
et environ 3500 masques ffp2 au cours de
ces dernières semaines
depuis ces dernières semaines nous
utilisons chaque jour 166 mille masques
chirurgicaux et 43 mille masques ffp2
donc ça vous donne l'ordre de grandeur
début mars nous disposions d'un million
de masques chirurgicaux dans nos stocks
+1 8 million qui a été commandé et la
commande s'est concrétisé quelques temps
après donc soit 3 millions de masques
chirurgicaux et environ un million de
masques ffp2 plus pour reprendre
effectivement les stocks que nous avions
des crises précédentes environ 3
millions de masques dont on pouvait
considérer qu'ils étaient au delà de la
limite de péremption
mais qui ont pu être utilisés et garder
pour éviter une pénurie
ensuite il ya eu des périodes difficiles
où nous avions une incertitude sur
combien de temps nous pourrions tenir
avant que comment de masques dits
périmés c'est ça ou du stock 3,1
millions 3,1 millions là la pénurie que
nous avons connue est une pénurie sur
les sur blues où on a eu quelques jours
pendant lesquels on a appelé la terre
entière pour trouver des cas il ya une
feinte de fourniture de surblouse appelé
la terre entière on a en fait partie de
ceux qui ont commandé des
l'utilisation de sacs plastiques
redécouper pour utilisant surblouse au
cas où et on en a commandé 1 2 million
on a testé la possibilité de laver des
blues pour pouvoir les récupérer et l'
usage de blues non jetables pour se
protéger cette période a été
particulièrement inconfortable pour nos
personnels pour nos personnels nous
avons à peu près 4800 personnes
identifiées comme ayant été atteintes
par le cos vide j'ai mentionné au début
de mon audition
le fait que nous avons eu cinq décès et
ce chiffre est sous-estimé par rapport à
la réalité des personnes qui ont été en
contact avec le co vide puisque nous
sommes en train de faire des sérologies
qui ne donne qu après coup les données
et je crois qu'il ya à peu près la
moitié des personnels de l'assistance
publique qui ont fait des sérologies on
se retrouve plutôt sur un taux à
posteriori de 11 12 13 % de de personnel
mais là aussi ce sont des taux qui ne
sont pas définitifs mais qui montrent
que pour un sur deux cd personnel qui ne
savaient pas qu'ils avaient été atteints
juste quand on regarde la cinétique la
la montée des contaminations se fait
pendant la deuxième quinzaine de mars et
en avril on voit déjà des croître le
nombre de personnels contaminés
chaque semaine au moment où le nombre de
patients qu'on prend en charge est le
plus élevé ensuite il faudra tout un
travail pour savoir quelles sont les
conditions de contamination et
confessions de protection et en terme de
date c'est le 1er mars qu'on demande que
le port du masque soit systématique dans
les services d'accueil des urgences le
service d'accueil en général et pour les
patients symptomatiques et la
généralisation à l'ensemble des
personnels administratifs inclus
et décidé le 19 mars sur les questions
que vous avez posé sur les instructions
d'abord sur le renoncement aux soins
sachez que pendant toute cette période
on a fait des transplantations les
grandes gares dont fonctionne et est à
l'hôpital ne faisait pas esquivé de ces
de ses missions même s'il ya eu
effectivement un fort taux de thébaux g
à sion est un renoncement aux soins de
patients quoi on a vu y compris dans la
période du mois de mai des patients qui
avait peur d'aller à l'hôpital
on a organisé des serres ddd circuits
distincts pour les patients et et je
pense que la possibilité de venir à
l'hôpital quand c'est nécessaire revient
il faut pas hésiter à continuer à faire
pezi passer le message qu'il vaut mieux
venir à l'hôpital quand on est appelé
pour une visite de contrôle ou pour une
coloscopie ou pour tous c'est plutôt que
de s'abstenir sur les questions qui sont
posées sur la les consignes de fin de
vie il ya effectivement un groupe de
travail qui a émis des consignes avec
éthiciens gériatre réanimateur et c'est
qu'ils sont cons a publié d'emblée sur
notre site
puis vous êtes un travail collégial et
je pourrais vous les fournir
après si vous le souhaitez les
professionnels ont réalisé ce travail là
assez tôt dans la crise je vais en
revenir à la question qui était posée
sur les pesanteurs et le système le plus
normé au monde
je peux vous donner quelques exemples
nous avons le droit de donner 15 heures
supplémentaires par mois à nos
personnels pour dépasser les 15 heures
il faut que j'envoie un courrier
motivant le fait qu'une période de crise
juste
fille qu'on puisse avoir 18 heures
supplémentaires au 20 heures
supplémentaires donc je fais en général
un courrier avant la grippe un courrier
avant la bronchiolite un courrier avant
la canicule pour demander l'autorisation
de pouvoir sortir de ce régime d'heures
supplémentaires je pense qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de pays dans lequel il faut
écrire au ministre
peut-être demeure directeur général de
la rs pour avoir le droit que les gens
puissent être là à leur poste de travail
quand on a besoin d'eux vous vous
interrogez sur les ratios de personnel
administratif par rapport aux personnels
soignants
nous nous devons payer 1500 personnes
pour vérifier les droits de mutuelle des
patients 1500 agents administratifs dont
le travail consiste consiste à vérifier
alors bien évidemment on appris des
patients mais ensuite pour pouvoir se
faire payer auprès de quelques centaines
de pilleurs différents auprès de
quelques centaines de pilleurs différent
on a à peu près 1500 agents qui font ce
travail j'ai proposé que ce travail ne
soit plus un travail d'hôpital dont on
peut être nombreux à considérer le
travail de l'hôpital est plutôt de
soigner les gens et donc par conséquent
on a proposé deux solutions le
directoire de la paix a proposé deux
solutions soit le système d'assurance
maladie prend en charge l'ensemble des
soins hospitaliers soit ça peut être la
caisse d'assurance maladie qui paye
l'hôpital puis ensuite se fait
rembourser
je pense qu'il ya des systèmes pour cela
mais effectivement je préférerais
pouvoir convertir ces personnes avec un
plan de formation efficace on aide
soignant ou en infirmier plutôt que dans
des éléments administratifs
je pense par exemple aussi que avoir des
personnels qui doivent aller vérifier
que les patients paye le supplément
chambre individuelle me paraissait
inappropriée avant la crise me paraît
très inapproprié après une crise pour
lequel l'objectif est de pouvoir mettre
tous les patients dans des chambres
individuelles plutôt que de leur
demander s'ils demandent une chambre
individuelle
voilà un autre exemple il ya beaucoup
d'exemples de cette nature je vais vous
en donner un autre le fait que quand
nous avons je parlais des lits fermés de
soins critiques et quand nous constatons
que il y à des infirmiers et des
infirmières qui ont du mal à aller
travailler en réanimation où ils vont
être soumis à d'autres contraintes que
d'autres à d'autres prises de risques
d'autres différends d'une
hospitalisation de jour en diabétologie
et que nous n'avons pas le droit de
faire une différence de rémunération
pour ces personnels parce qu'il faudrait
que décret sur la nba y soient modifiées
ou que telle ou telle autre
nous considérons que on serait capable
de respecter les contrats qu'on nous
donne mais je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux
que nous puissions adapter cela pour
avoir des lits ouverts pour la
bronchiolite l'hiver pour la réanimation
toute l'année plutôt que de constater
que nous ne pouvons pas ouvrir ses
lignes
voilà le type de souplesse qui pourrait
donner aux établissements hospitaliers
pour qu'ils puissent mieux faire leur
travail au service des patients rapporte
à peut-être une précision sur la
définition à la fois des stocks de
matériel de protection d'équipements de
protection individuelle ou douze masques
que chaque établissement constituée dans
le cadre de la circulaire du secrétariat
général à la défense sécurité nationale
de 2013 on en a beaucoup parlé ici
comment ces stocks sont définis sur
quelle base vous les aviez défini et est
ce qu'il faisait l'objet d'un contrôle
ou d'une évaluation notamment des ars
respectivement comment on a mesuré
l'évaluation de ses stocks
ensuite j'ai été un peu interpellé vous
nous avez dit monsieur gautier donc le
port du masque généralisé est intervenu
chez vous le 23 mars
et chez vous suire ch
19 mars c'est à dire presque un mois
après le déclenchement du pick and italy
quoi donc ce que c'est pas un délai très
tardif et qui a quelque part pu
fragiliser la protection des personnels
soignants dans ce mois où le nombre de
cas a faim on savait que là que la vague
était devant nous et vous vous la
subissiez des japon
vous avez raison il ya deux éléments qui
ont été pris en compte
il y a l'élément des consignes établi
par les au conseil et les hygiénistes
qui
[Musique]
on conduit d'abord avoir les conditions
de porc de masse assez restrictive plus
ouverte au 1er mars et ensuite
généraliser peu près trois semaines
après et puis la prise en compte des
stocks
moi j'ai été confronté à cette question
le doyen view on a été le témoin fin
février où la question s'est posée quand
on est premier patient prix de l'oise
venu à thenon des premières
contaminations intra hospitalière et où
la question a été posée par certains
de passage à la protection des 100000
personnel systématiquement ou de
maintien d'une protection plus graduées
moi j'ai pris en compte le fait que si
je pèse 7 février à la consommation de
160 mille masques
d'emblée nous risquions quelques jours
après de pouvoir être en difficulté pour
ceux qui étaient aux devants dans les
unités de soins critiques ou dans les
services
recevant des patients qu'aux vide
donc oui nous avons ya eu une évolution
dans les doctrines clairement j'allais
dire indépendante de nous et il ya une
prise en compte de la difficulté qu'on
avait à pouvoir reconstituer des stocks
pendant cette période là donc les deux
ont joué et bien évidemment chez les
gens
aucun doute que le fait que nous soyons
aujourd'hui à masquer pour tous à toute
heure quelque chose sur laquelle nous ne
reviendrions pas en arrière en cas de
deuxième vague bien évidemment oui je
rejoins tout à fait pardonnez moi oui je
rejoins tout à fait ce que ce que martin
je viens d'évoquer on peut distinguer
trois phases on a une phase du 22
janvier au 4 mars qui répondent
effectivement un avis national du haut
conseil de santé publique et un mars du
28 février
une deuxième phase du 4 mars au 23 mars
avec également un avis du des société
française d'hygiène hospitalière
et puis cette décision d'élargissement
nous l'apprenons si dans un contexte où
longuement discuté les dispositions de
protection pour nous était indispensable
pour les sujets contacts des collègues
qui étaient réputés positif et comme n'a
eu une forme de dissémination à
l'intérieur de l'établissement
de proche en proche on s'est rendu à
l'évidence de la nécessité absolue de
prendre une décision de basque pour tous
et c'est venu comme cela encore une
forme déclinaison d'abord des
différentes doctrines n'a jamais été à
l'écart par rapport la doctrine jodie
également que par rapport à la doctrine
de n'ont jamais été en situation de
rupture nette
ça c'est très important dans le cadre de
l'approvisionnement liées aux stock
national jeunes et rappelé les chiffres
tout à l'heure 1 2 million de masques
pour le chu de strasbourg
mais cette doctrine généralisation est
venu effectivement dans la suite pour
nous d'une politique de prévention des
sujets contacts décoller qui avait été
testé positif
vous n'êtes pas répondu à ma première
question sur la définition des moyennes
dactique et mais vous n'avez certes pas
été en rupture mais dans votre réponse
vous indiquer qu'il ya eu une forme de
régulation
si si les masques avait été utilisée de
façon générale plus tôt vous vous auriez
été en rupture
oui en l'explication dans le stock
tactique répond à une instruction de
il porte essentiellement sur la
définition d'un pcem2 de tenues
protection individuelle très normé
d'ailleurs équipons il n'ya pas les
masques d'ailleurs très peu de masques
effectivement puisque encore une fois d
une préoccupation qui est un peu
différente avec des tenues de protection
individuelle quant à la façon dont nous
gérons nos stocks je le rappelle elle
provenait de la noce stocks de
précaution qui en termes de consommation
normale celle du strasbourg donné 30
jours pour les masques chirurgicaux 80
jours pour les masques ffp2 et avec le
principe du réapprovisionnement de façon
illimitée c'est un non limités en termes
de quantité et c'est un principe qui
aurait pu marcher de façon efficace il
n'y avait pas eu de rupture de la
filière d'approvisionnement ce qui était
au moment où nous avons établi cette
doctrine d'une certaine manière assez
imprévisible merci pierre dharréville
groupe gdr
oui merci madame la présidente au fil
des questions
ce sentiment s'amende légèrement mais
j'ai un peu eu l'impression quand même
dans la présentation des fêtes des
choses d'une forme de positive attitude
est la question que je me pose est ce
que vous n'avez pas été en colère quand
même à la place où vous êtes face à la
situation dans laquelle vous vous êtes
retrouvé parce qu'en tout cas moi la
colère j'ai ressenti chez les personnels
les gens qui m'ont interpellé tout au
long de la crise notamment au début mais
tout au long de la crise sur les
pénuries répétées dont vous nous dites
on n'a pas été en rupture
je me permets d'insister sûr ce point là
vous n'avez pas été en rupture parce que
aussi il ya eu effectivement une sorte
de de gestion pour essayer d'économiser
les stocks et donc enfin je pense que
vous avez été confronté à des
difficultés majeures
je crois que vous devriez nous dire
comme ça parce que parce que nous avons
besoin de savoir
en réalité alors après que ça a été
compliqué à gérer
tout le monde peut l'entendre premier
première remarque question que je
voudrais poser sur les stocks
est-ce que avant la crise vous n'avez
pas déjà été amenée à produire des
arbitrages sur l'alimentation régulière
de ses stocks au regard des moyens dont
dispose l'hôpital public sur était-il à
jour en réalité au delà des besoins de
la crise etait-il à jour au moment où la
crise et à survenue une question
peut-être sur
les la distribution des masques au delà
des services consacrés à la gestion du
coc vite parce que là aussi peut-être
que le virus a circulé dans ces endroits
là alors que la protection dans l'est
dans les services co vide et est elle
sans doute assurer de bonnes façons
troisième élément sur les tests comment
avez vous vécu les consignes transmises
d'ailleurs les consignes sur les tests
vis-à-vis du personnel je parle
vis-à-vis du personnel lui-même est ce
que vous avez pu avoir une une dit va
disposer de tests suffisant pour
connaître un peu de l'évolution du virus
aussi dans les dents les personnels
hospitaliers
enfin je voudrais savoir sur le
personnel qui a été mobilisé
si les primes laurent et trc y compris à
ceux qui ont été parfois victimes de
maladie pendant cette période et qui
n'ont pas assisté à l'ensemble de la
gestion de la crise
merci à jen t merci mme la présidente
nous sommes là pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé voir en
tirer leçon pour voir ce qu'on peut
faire peut-être de mieux la prochaine
fois j'aurai voulu revenir sur
l'adaptation du système qui de mon point
de vue de néophytes m'a semblé tout à
fait remarquable qui est l'adaptation en
termes de nombre de lits on l'a beaucoup
critiquée et notamment fait des
comparaisons avec notamment l'allemagne
et moi j'ai compris du système français
qu'on avait trois types de livres les
avait évoqué tout à l'heure les lits de
réanimation les lits de soins intensifs
les lits de soins de suite et que c'est
finalement ces trois formats de lit qui
nous sont donnés cette souplesse de nous
permettre de nous adapter à la vague qui
arrivait avec néanmoins puisque nous
n'étions pas complètement préparé j'ai
compris des soucis d'équipement et de
personnel vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure donc ma question est la suivante
est ce que finalement ce système n'est
pas le bon système de pouvoir s'adapter
assez facilement at on vraiment besoin
de deux fois plus de lits de réanimation
comme on l'a dit que l'allemagne en
possède ce que ce serait vraiment
justifiée par temps normal je dirais
et si nous voulions nous préparer à une
autre mise en tension du système de
combien d'équipement devrions-nous nous
prémunir et de personnel pour pouvoir
adapter rapidement notre système et de
la même façon s'agissant des personnels
administratifs que vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure on a beaucoup parlé de la
comparaison entre le taux de personnes
administratif entre la france et
l'allemagne
nous avons aussi auditionné madame
bachelot qui nous a dit qu'appelle-t-on
au personnel administratif
peut-on considérer qu'un technicien de
radiologie est à personnel administratif
je voulais aussi avoir votre retour là
dessus merci merci martin wagner
merci madame la présidente messieurs les
directeurs plusieurs questions très
précises à monsieur hirsch
vous avez déclaré il me semble début
mars
très clairement que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine n'a jamais fonctionné sur
quiconque
l'avez vous dit sur des bases
scientifiques et si oui lesquelles
avez-vous bien adressé des consignes
pour ne pas l'utiliser dans vos services
si oui pourquoi et un essai avec le taux
si l'uimm abl pardon si c'est pas tout à
fait justement bien dit et mis en place
dans vos établissements le 27 avril vous
intervenez pour vous réjouir
peut-être des premiers effets de cette
molécule le 29 avril le ministre de la
santé lui même reprend vos propos et le
30 avril le comité démissionne au fond
il n'y at il pas eu perte de chance pour
par rapport à l'utilisation de cette
molécule pour monsieur gautier deux
petites questions est-ce que vous pouvez
préciser s'il vous plaît parce que
j'étais j'ai beaucoup suivi avec l'
agence régionale de santé il madame la
préfète ce qui s'est passé dans le grand
est
à partir de quand avez vous pu tester
votre votre personnel
il me semble vous avez précisé 650
personnes ont été ou 6 ans ont été
infectées est-ce que
vous n'étiez pas obligé par carence en
personnel de redemander à ses personnels
de revenir assez vite en service et s'il
n'y avait et s'il y avait eu une
gouvernance peut-être plus souple qui
vous au réveil était offerte en absence
de 2 des actions prévenante de l' agence
régionale de santé
est ce que la coopération avec les
normes cliniques privées reina aurait pu
être différente et notamment en matière
de personnel puisque certains personnels
arena on sont restés en chômage
technique pendant toute cette période de
confinement je vous remercie messieurs
merci incessants de forget merci madame
la présidente madame messieurs mais qui
sont vont également pour monsieur hirsch
parce que quand je vous vois assez
prompt et rapides à réagir et ça a des
avantages comme des inconvénients j'ai
bien compris vous avez écrit cette
lettre pour finalement défendre le
personnel de la phb
je pense que c'est un réflexe presse
naturel et normal en tant qu' en tant
que directeur une belle institution
comme ça néanmoins vous venez nous dire
et d'avouer que ce cette photo qui sort
de vos registres de lui verser du
registre eva 43 % de mortalité dans la
php au 14 avril
c'est en effet juste c'est une photo
juste j'ai pas compris quelque chose que
vous dites on est on oublie 50% des
patients est ce que vous parlez donc de
ceux qui ont survécu qui sont forcément
encore dans des lits la même c'est la
même chose partout qu'on fait un taux de
mortalité vous êtes scientifique
également vous savez comme moi soit on
l'a on a la chance rétrospectivement en
intégrer sur un nom sont le fant en réel
puis c'est une valeur a intenté puis
finalement c'est la même chose un peu
dans toutes les institutions c'est comme
ça qu'on a suivi et d'egypte d'incidence
prévalence à des taux de mortalité la
l'évolution du coville 19
et puis il ya cette histoire de taux si
l'immeuble est allé très vite également
le 27 avril a déclaré que c'était très
bien très positif vous avez même dit
qu'un accueil sceptique et on ne le dira
dans le d'un cadre un peu prospectifs
comme ça néanmoins il ya eu ces
démissions en bloc du comité de suivi le
30 avril j'aimerais savoir si c'est des
retentissements sur l'évolution de cette
étude également comme ma collègue martin
v ner et puis donc simplement vous êtes
allez vite sur cette lettre mais
finalement en accusant le professeur à
ou de propos diffamatoires et moi je
m'inquiète quand
vite comme ça vous vous mettiez à risque
d'être vous même diffamatoire ce
professeur out simplement je pense qu'il
serait jusque qu'on apaise ces choses là
et puis qu'on n'avait pas dans ces
histoires de personne à personne je
pense qu'on a tous à gagner compris
admettre les erreurs et même si la photo
d'une mortelle d'une surmortalité à un
moment donné dans un endroit à un autre
existe il faut savoir pourquoi comment
et le but c'est pas de s'accuser les uns
les autres
merci je pense que le rôle d'un
directeur d'un grand établissement de
santé confrontés à la crise c'est de
savoir si ce mets en colère ou pas
savoir si c'est ici là l écoute des
inquiétudes et les colères et s'il prend
les mesures pour les protéger
soit les mesures internes soit en
demandant les mesures je pense que vous
n'avez peut-être entendu allez dire
qu'il y avait un moment où effectivement
si on ne débloquait pas un certain
nombre de choses on pouvait être en ris
je pense que j'étais dans mon rôle ma
question était pas de piquer une colère
ni d'être sourd aux colères et comment
est ce qu'on a fait pendant toute cette
période et j'étais encore ce matin avec
le comité technique d'établissement avec
les différents représentants qu'il
reconnaissait ça sera en pve que la
manière qui rendait hommage à la
direction pour la transparence
l'écoutent et la prison cas et la prise
en compte des préoccupations avec des
choses qu'on n'a réussi d'autres qu'on
faisait moins bien mais avec un souci
permanent de partager la transparence on
réunissait les représentants élus des
personnels plusieurs fois par semaine en
conférence téléphonique pourront en dire
ou non est avec les stocks
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire qu'est ce
qu'on attendait comme on faisait avec
les uns les autres
justement pour pas imposer des mesures
qui auraient été cachées par je ne sais
quelles intentions ou de cacher nos
difficultés
ce que je sais dire sans avoir fini leur
et ex que le facteur le plus limitant le
facteur le plus limites en avant les
conditions matérielles ou les conditions
spatiales
ce sont les personnels et que d'emblée
on peut dire qu'on doit faire un travail
sur la réserve
comment les réserves constituent les
réserves de personnel comment elles sont
actionnés comment on forme je vais vous
donner un exemple très concret c'est
pour ne pas se retrouver en difficulté
quand on a à augmenter le lien de nombre
de lits de réanimation
on doit avoir des personnels hors
réanimation qui restent
formé à la réanimation qui sont passés
quelques semestre quelques années en
réanimation qu'ils ont peut-être dans
une autre unité dont on maintient les
compétences dont on maintient la
formation qui sont entre guillemets
réquisitionna bloqua ou qui dont on
reconnaît l'effort d'être formé de
participer à des exercices et qui
puisent va ça ça me parait majeur ça me
paraît faisable
ça nécessite pas d investissement
pendant des années et c'est des choses
qui font la différence pour être moins
dépendant de détention qu'il peut y
avoir sur les personnels s'il ya quelque
chose d'essentiel
il me semble qu'elle est et je les
trouvais on entend souvent des prises de
paroles davantage sur sur les conditions
matérielles
alors que les conditions personnelles me
semble majeur ensuite vous m'avez
demandé si j'ai donné des consignes pour
ne pas donner de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
la réponse est non je n'ai pas nous
n'avons pas donné de consignes pour ne
pas donner de l'hydroxyde rock est
d'abord parce que nous avons donné des
ventes a besoin de donner de consignes
pour que les médecins prescrivent et je
crois n'avoir jamais donné moi même je
crois
sauf des consignes élaboré en tout cas
pendant la crise les seules consignes
qu'on donnait était élaboré
conjointement par les représentants
médicaux
nous n'avons pas donné ses consignes et
vous pouvez avoir d'ailleurs
l'augmentation de la consommation de
plaquer deal dans les
hôpitaux d'île de france pendant cette
période là par rapport à la consommation
normale nous avons et nous avons bien
fait fait un texte commun avec les
représentants de la recherche de la
clinique le directeur médical de crise
pour rappeler que quand on utilisait un
médicament en dehors des règles
d'utilisation prévue d'un médicament
il fallait le faire dans un cadre
collégiale non pas pour l'interdire ou
non pas pour le promouvoir
mais pour qu'il y ait un cadre
collégiale prenant en compte l'ensemble
des données c'est-à-dire les risques les
bénéfices les l'intérêt plutôt de
pouvoir sauvegarder les possibilités de
tester des médicaments plutôt que de se
retrouver avec un usage des médicaments
qui fait qu'on se retrouve trois mois
après sans un embryon de réponse à la
question est-ce que c'est efficace ou
non
efficace sur les 7 10 corps immuno dont
l'un des bras et l'utilisation de ce
médicament qui s'appelle le dos il y du
mahb
nous avons effectivement et moins pas
tout seul avec les investigateurs avec
les responsables de ce programme donné
des données relativement prudente le 27
avril en faisant état de résultats
prometteurs dans ce dilemme qui est
est-ce qu'on attend que les résultats
soient publiés
ou est-ce que si on voit des éléments
qui ont un élément particulier on le
partage avec l'ensemble des acteurs
7 j'en ai suivi d'une polémique
une démission on a renommé le un comité
l'essai a été prolongée monitorer sera
publié
et nous avons pris l'engagement pour
éviter des polémiques de ne pas re
communiquer sur ses résultats avant la
publication scientifique dont j'espère
qu'elle se fera bientôt et qui
permettront d'avoir des réponses à aux
inquiétudes que vous formulez mais ce
que nous avons fait c'est effectivement
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de perte de
chance
ensuite on interroge en disant est ce
que je suis prompt à répondre trop vite
alors soyons précis
mon rôle n'est pas de faire la politique
des pourcentages où la politique des
statistiques et si un des experts que
vous aviez auditionnée sans prendre
parti ou sans vouloir attaquer sur
vouloir défendre une thèse avait dit il
ya un certain moment où le taux de
mortalité était environ de 40 % à 41 % à
45 %
j'aurais pas écrit là on est dans un
cadre tout à fait différent on est dans
la cas dans lequel à l'appui d'une thèse
voulant dire qu'on a mal traiter les
malades on prend effectivement une
diapositive non valides de fin juin du
14 avril
comme les américains qui à un moment
donné ont publié un taux de mortalité de
80% dans la réanimation puis on dit en
fait c'est ça va c'est pas le vrai taux
est et à ces choses là sont nous aider
on a fait le choix
jour après jour d'avoir des tableaux de
bord pour suivre ce qui se passait jour
après jour vous pourriez au contraire me
reprocher de ne pas avoir de tableau de
bord jour après jour sur ce qui se
passait et je peux vous fournir
l'ensemble de ses tableaux de bords y
compris la série des tableaux de bord
jour après jour pendant les 90 jours de
crise avec les 50 pages de ce tableau de
bord sur l'ensemble des données qui
permet d'être fait et les
interprétations qu'on en donnait pour
pouvoir aider à piloter cette crise donc
s'il s'agissait simplement de ça je
n'aurais pas fait mon rôle encore une
fois n'est pas de faire la police des
pourcentages mais si c'est pour induire
la commission d' enquête sur une piste
dans lequel en prenant une donnée un
jour données biaisées partiel en la
comparant à une autre dont je ne connais
pas la source pour dire et cent mille
personnes des hôpitaux
on mal traités les patients les ont pas
bien pris en charge on assurer un taux
de mortalité plus élevé qu'ailleurs par
leurs pratiques thérapeutiques et la
manière dont il travaille là c'est mon
rôle de réagir promptement et de réagir
effectivement en vous donnant les
données je vous ai donné les données
avec leurs limites les données 2 civique
les données actuelles les données
maximale les données et les raisons dans
son lit et les éléments qui les font
varier qui sont différents de ceux que
j'ai lu et entendu dans la mise en cause
de l'assistance publique et des trente
neuf hôpitaux que nous formons merci
salon poursuivre avec jean jacques
gauthier merci bien la présidente trois
points sur les taux de mortalité ont pas
opposer les soignants et les
établissements entrent dans une sorte de
compétition macabre funèbres et funeste
mais simplement de constater que ces
taux de mortalité vous l'avez dit évolué
et surtout que ces taux de mortalité ont
été plus graves observés habituellement
plus grave qu'estimé au départ est plus
grave qu'annoncé par monsieur salomon le
17 avril puisqu'il est chiffré à 10 %
donc des taux de 30 35 % 40 % ont été
observés vous l'avez dit hey hey le
professeur comme d'ailleurs de la pitié
salpêtrière l'a dit aussi
fin juin le 27 juin sur les tests vrai
vous interroger sur la stratégie de
dépistage l'heure pas tellement sur le
personnel les agents mais sur sur la
population
sur le nombre de personnes testées au
niveau de la population à se joue à la
fois en valeur absolue mais surtout en
si l'éthique est ce qu'il ya eu une
montée en puissance à partir de quand
avez vous testé les premiers les
premiers public et surtout à partir de
quand avez vous testé des patients
asymptomatiques et pas uniquement ceux
hospitalisés en réa qui sont évidemment
potentiellement contagieux et puis
dernière question sur les transferts
sanitaire ci s'adresse d'ailleurs à la
fois l'île de france et au grand test
question toute simple
pouvez-vous nous certifier qu'il n'y
avait pas de place en hospitalisation
privée pour tous les patients transférés
à l'autre bout de la france ou à
l'étranger
nicolas des moulins merci j'aimerais
revenir sur les évacuations sanitaires
simplement pour que vous soyez un tout
petit peu plus précis vous avez parlé de
deux transferts liés bien sûr à des
problèmes de l'effectif de lits mais
surtout de soins adaptés si j'ai bien
compris est ce que vous pouvez
simplement de détailler un parcours pour
comprendre un peu comment ça fonctionne
au niveau de ces transferts certains
patients étaient transférés en occitanie
en aquitaine et d'autre part donner des
petites précisions sur le processus de
décision de ces transferts merci merci
boris vallot je veux dire qu'on vous
écoute on à la fois on sent que ça a été
extrêmement mobilisateur extrêmement
prenant très difficile mais on a du mal
à identifier finalement ont été vos
difficultés puisque vous l'avez
surmonter c'est ce que vous nous dites
pour préparer l'avenir et même si j'ai
bien compris on conçoit que les retours
d'expérience sont en cours qu'on a
évidemment et aucune certitude sur
l'hypothèse d'une seconde vague
il faut pour ce qui nous concerne aussi
l'envisager
d'où la demande d'avoir des réponses
aussi précise que possible sur la
question de des stocks stratégiques
il ya un débat sur les stocks est ce
qu'ils ont fait défaut est ce que
finalement il faut reconstituer des
stocks stratégiques d'état ffp2 est-ce
que vous même vous devez avoir des
stocks beaucoup plus importants
considérez vous que la psp était prête à
gérer cette crise sanitaire
considérez-vous que l'austérité
budgétaire a eu une incidence sur la
gestion de cette crise quelles
initiatives vous semble opportune à
garder et quelles leçons tirez-vous de
la crise dieu merci sur les évacuations
sanitaires deux éléments de réponse
premièrement sur le processus de
décision tout cas pour la région ile de
france
nous avons demandé des évacuations
sanitaires et ensuite nous avons obtenu
l'accord de la rs et du comité chorus du
ministère à la fois sur le nombre et sur
les régions de destination dans une
discussion sur comment faire en sorte
que les régions restent disponibles pour
leurs propres patients ou que l'île de
france ne soit pas favorisé par rapport
à l'est etc
donc il ya eu un processus de décision
relativement rapide mais à partir d'une
analyse et d'une analyse qui répondent à
une seule obsession en fait nous notre
obsession c'était pas de se retrouver à
connaître le moment où on serait
dépassée par rapport à nombre de malades
par rapport à nombre de prises en charge
un compte tenu d d d ouverture que l'on
faisait et de ne pas jouer à pile ou
face et pas attendre le dernier jour
pour dire là on a mis le dernier malade
dans le dernier lit disponible donc
c'est pour ça que quand on a vu que
notre visibilité par rapport à la
cinétique du nombre de malades à prendre
en charge et du nombre de lits
disponibles se réduisait à quelques
jours à une semaine de se dire c'est ce
moment là qu'il faut déclencher les
évacuations sanitaires qui ont été
faites
sous l'autorité du professeur hors ue
sur des critères médicaux de gravité
c'est à dire à la fois pas trop grave
par rapport aux conditions de transport
et de malades ayant besoin de
réanimation pour pouvoir permettre à
d'autres patients d'accéder à la
réanimation dans les jours qui suivaient
et avec systématiquement l'accord des
familles bien évidemment et avec un
suivi qu'on a mis en place d'emblée de
telle sorte qu'ils aient un suivi
médical de liaison entre nos équipes
médicales les équipes médicales
d'accueil ce qui nous a permis à tout
moment de savoir où étaient nos patients
comment exhalait à quel moment ils
pouvaient éventuellement revenir et quel
était leur devenir dans les trois
filières que vous avez évoquées vous
m'avez dit qu'on donnait l'impression
d'avoir surmonté les difficultés et du
coup est ce que ces difficultés existait
je savais que ça soit clair oui les
difficultés et est immense je ne sais
pas si on les a toutes surmontées
mais on a s'est mobilisée pour le faire
nous n'avions pas connaissance à ce
moment là au tout début de la crise
de quel était l'état des stocks
nationaux par rapport à ce dont on avait
connaissance il ya quelques années
c'est des choses premièrement qu'on a
découverte en même temps que vous vous
nous avez demandé si l'hôpital nord
avait obérer la capacité des cuvées de
nom puisqu'il n'est pas encore construit
donc on n'a pas encore dépensé d'argent
pour pour l'hôpital nord mais s'ils
décident élargi la question en disant
est ce qu effectivement le besoin de
financer des investissements a des
répercussions sur notre exploitation
courante la réponse est oui
la réponse est clairement oui et c'est
pas un scoop quoi et nous avons fait ces
dernières années
l'effort de ne pas obérer le futur en
maintenant un taux d'investissement
extrêmement important parce qu'il faut
renouveler le matériel
parce qu'il faut avoir des équipements
qu'ils soient à jour parce qu'il faut
avoir des normes de sécurité dans nos
hôpitaux parce qu'il faut refaire un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux un taux de
vétusté qui est élevé de faire en sorte
que la d1000 paraît du coup c'est un
effort supplémentaire sur l'exploitation
courante
ça c'est clair évident et c'est pas un
scoop d'aujourd'hui dont d'où
l'importance de pouvoir refinancer un
certain nombre d'investissements en
maintenant l'exploitation courante forte
ce qui me permet de faire le lien avec
votre question sur l'austérité
budgétaire que vous avez posé moi je dis
ce que je dis depuis plusieurs années je
dis que l'hôpital je les écris dans un
livre il ya trois ans l'hôpital public
français courent un risque depuis des
années compte tenu du salaire des
paramédicaux pas attendu la crise pour
regarder qui a été la comparaison pour
entendre la colère des personnes qui
travaillent à l'hôpital et leurs
difficultés de logement qui probablement
plus aiguë en région ile de france que
dans d'autres régions
j'observe toujours que dans les autres
pays
les rémunérations ne sont pas identiques
pour tous les métiers
toutes les contraintes et toutes les
régions on tient compte du coût de la
vie
je pense que c'est assez logique de
tenir compte du coût de la vie du coût
du logement pour fixer les rémunérations
et que si on n'en tient pas compte on a
des effets qui sont des effets délétères
là où le coût de la vie est élevé et
donc cet élément là si vous suivez mon
raisonnement qui est de dire que ce qui
nous a mis le plus haut risque qui me
permet de répondre quand vous dites est
ce que vous estimez que vous étiez près
le
1er mars vous aurais répondu non je
pense que bien pourquoi je vous aurais
répondu non je rêve non parce qu' un
certain nombre de lits de soins
critiques fermé pour défaut de perth
pour manque de personnel etc
donc j'ai toujours reconnu que nous
n'avions pas aborder la crise dans les
meilleures conditions
est ce que à la fois les efforts pardon
de répéter mais remarquable de
l'ensemble des équipes qu'elles soient
administratives techniques soignante se
toutes catégories à compenser en partie
cela et deuxièmement les conditions dans
lesquelles nous avons pu travailler
pendant ces périodes là c'est à dire de
pouvoir effectivement dérogé à sa tante
de choses pouvoir faire appel à un
certain nombre de deux renforts disposer
des primes
gevo kg pas répondu tout à l'heure je
pense que je suis un des premiers à
avoir demandé publiquement à ce qu'il ya
des primes pour les personnels qui
travaillait dans ces services là parce
que ça me paraissait juste justice et je
trouvais ça compliqué de demander aux
gens d'aller travailler dans des
conditions aussi difficiles sans leur
dire qu'il serait tenu compte de cela
j'ai pas répondu complètement mais j'en
profite
on a fait en sorte de pré payé
rapidement la prime fin mai et puis
ensuite de regarder quels sont les cas
dans lequel ils auraient dû être payées
et pas être payés mais plutôt de payer
je pense 90 % des primes fin mai pour
que les personnels qui était en
surcharge de travail depuis février
n'attendent pas juin ou juillet qu'on
ait regardé chacun des cas
individuellement et puis il ya des
rattrapage à faire
on fera bien évidemment ces rattrapages
et dans des conditions dans lesquelles
le fait d'être écartée du travail parce
qu'on a eus qu'ovide n'écarte pas de la
prime en revanche une personne qui était
en congé maladie pour une autre raison
pendant cette période-là n'est pas
éligible à cette prime parce qu'elle va
de même comme comme le décret le prévoit
est ce qu'il ya des innovations qui sont
nés pendant cette crise qu'il faut
garder la réponse est trois fois oui
j'ai très rapide mais je vous enverrai
des documents qu vie d'homme a permis à
la médecine de ville à la médecine
hospitalière de travailler ensemble de
faire de la télésurveillance de prendre
en charge des patients dans des
conditions de bonne qualité sans qu'ils
aient à se déplacer et ce genre
d'initiatives dont on trouvera le
prolongement dans le service dans le dax
est ce qu'on appelle le sas et on
travaille avec les collègues libéraux
pour pouvoir donner une suite à ces
modes de fonctionnement je pense que la
crise a montré qu'on savait le faire
qu'on savait le faire ensemble qu'on
savait le faire dans des conditions de
qualité et de sécurité soins forte
le programme comme ihsan n'est bien
évidemment pas interrompu maintenant il
a montré aussi qu'on savait former des
personnels rapidement qu'on savait
mélanger des personnels et des renforts
et des volontaires qu'on savait faire
toute une série de choses qu'on n'osait
pas faire jusqu'à présent
il ya vraiment beaucoup d'initiatives
pour ce qui nous concerne à l'assistance
publique
nous avons monté un fonds qui s'appelle
le fond après où nous demandons à celles
et ceux qui ont pris l'initiative
certaine que nous connaissons pas de
pouvoir les déclarer pour pouvoir les
financer
pour les prolongements pour les
prolonger et qu'elle ne s'arrête pas
aujourd'hui
et puis il a d'autres qui pourront
peut-être faire école ailleurs comme il
ya des choses qui sont faites ailleurs
et qui font école à l'assistance
publique
monsieur le directeur de l'ap-hp vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure dans les
enjeux dans les difficultés
la question du personnel évoquant la
constitution d'une réserve plus plus
plus élaborés peut-être mais vous avez
ouvert une piste en 1 il faudrait plus
de souplesse qu'est ce que ça signifie
la souplesse sur le statut du personnel
sur capacité à recruter de façon plus
plus facile plus de rémunérer de façon
plus aussi plus facile
comment vous définiriez cette notion de
souplesse d'une piste important je pense
dans les propositions que nous serons
amenés à formuler je vous propose
d'utiliser la faculté que vous avez
octroyés et de proposer aux médecins de
répondre donc je vais m'exprimer
donc je suis effectivement en termes de
souplesse de recrutement c'est une chose
je pense que le point par exemple si on
s'intéresse au personnel de réanimation
il y a une on a reconnu au cours de
cette crise à quel point leurs
compétences étaient spécifiques et que
un infirmier ou une infirmière de
ranimation disposait de compétences et
d'aptitudes à les mettre en oeuvre très
spécifiques
il ya actuellement une démarche qui est
soutenu par les sociétés savantes qui
essayent effectivement de permettre de
reconnaître qu' il y a une compétence
spécifique qui dit reconnaître qu'il ya
une compétence spécifique dit
probablement pouvoir le reconnaître
aussi financièrement et pouvoir
typiquement tout à l'heure martin hier
je vous parlais de la nbi et des prix
mais de pouvoir effectivement noté que
ces gens là ont des compétences
supplémentaires et donc pouvoir le
reconnaître pour l'instant par exemple
typiquement ce n'est pas possible
une question membre du conseil
scientifique que vous connaissez bien
lilas bouadma nous a fait part de son
ses critiques sur les respirateurs qui
ont été commandés un peu en urgence en
disant qu'ils étaient totalement
inadapté puis une question bête sur le
le rapport de la fédération nationale
des sapeurs-pompiers qui est sorti qui
évoqué on va auditionner les samu mais
c'est en disant que le taux de réponse
le délai de réponse bardon étaient 45
minutes pour le samu de paris et de 4 37
minutes pour le samu 95 printemps une
perte de deux chances notamment pour les
les malades qui n'étaient pas concernés
par le cos vide donc bon je sais qu'il
ya eu des réponses officielles qui ont
été faites mais peu
être rapidement votre appréciation sur
sur ces questions très médicale sur ces
deux points dans les respirateurs qui
ont été commandés un certain nombre
venait de réserve ancien qui était de la
réserve et prusse et qui avait été
constitué un moment on pensait qu'on
aura besoin de respirateurs notamment
pour faire face à des attaques toxiques
et donc avec des respirateurs assez
simple qui effectivement sur les
patients qu'on avait dans le cadre de la
crise qu vide était insuffisant
néanmoins ces respirateur on n'a pas eu
à les utiliser et donc on a pu faire
face à des respirateurs intermédiaire
n'était pas allée super haut de gamme et
des respirateurs intermédiaire à titre
d'exemple c'est respirateur
intermédiaires qui ont été commandés ou
équiper entièrement le nouveau bâtiment
qu'on a ouvert à l'ap-hp à henri mondor
qui était équipé tous les lits est
équipé avec ses respirateur je vais
terminer juste par une remarque sur la
critique qui et les samu ont été
débordés l'augmentation x 4 dans
certains s'amusent
si vous regardez au niveau national
l'augmentation des appels vers le 18
c'est au maximum
à ma connaissance de l'ordre de 1,2
comment imaginer que si les samu avait
été réellement débordés que les patients
n'arrivait pas à joindre un samu qu'ils
ne se soient pas immédiatement
répercutée sur d'autres numéros
d'urgence et que ça ne se soit pas vu or
ceci n'est pas survenu vous venez à
d'écouté l'audition de christophe
gauthier directeur du chu de strasbourg
et de martin hirsch président des
hôpitaux de paris
le patron de l'ap-hp a largement démenti
les accusations de didier rahout je
réfute ce qui a été dit sur notre
négligence ou notre incompétence c'est
faux faux
l'ap-hp n'a pas laissé repartir chez lui
un patient malade faut le taux de
mortalité en réanimation n'était pas de
43% à paris et de 16% à marseille comme
l'expliqué le professeur marseillais
l'audition et toutes celles menées par
la commission denquête sont à revoir
tout l'été sur lcp et sur notre site
internet
lcp point fr